hey guys hi everyone you know nikita my
wife right you've seen her in a few
videos
well
nikita is starting her own youtube
channel we know there's been a few of
you that asked for this especially a lot
of women for the 15 of women that's on
my channel yeah
but now you can see nikita's channel yes
so tell them what is it all about why
don't i show you my trailer first here
it goes
i'm not strong
i'm not pretty
i want to be her and have her life
[Music]
i'm such a failure
how can anyone love me
it's so hard to be a woman
i can't do this
what do you believe
don't let yourself be defined by other
people and what you are not
define yourself by what you are
your worth is far above rubies
you are clothed in strength and honor
you were made to love
and be loved
you are kind and courageous
you are strong
you are beautiful
you are able to do
many things
you are a virtuous woman
and we are warriors
wow that's awesome that's really awesome
i'm so proud of you thank you oh my
goodness if that doesn't excite women
all around the world to come and follow
your channel to watch the videos i don't
know what will because that's that's
really good it's better than mine no
it's not when i started my channel
i was terrible i was speaking like a
robot and don't go watch those first
three years ago those videos well
perhaps everybody has to start somewhere
there's a beginning for everything
that's true that's true but she's so
good i mean she's a natural in front of
the camera
yeah i'm really proud of you so much
so the channel is basically going to be
the same as daniel's means lifestyle or
similar but just for women
and i'm also going to include a little
bit more content of our lives behind the
scenes you know and also our two fur
kids that we have and some of the deeper
issues that some of our women deal with
you know we're going to talk about that
and discuss a few things and oh my boy
does women talk about a lot of things
just be careful not to mention things
that i need to check the videos before
you ask me yes of course of course so if
you guys are curious to really see what
is our life like behind the scenes
subscribe now her channel is already
alive we'll add it for you in the video
description as well and then support us
share her channel i mean call your mom
call your aunt call your sisters your
girlfriends every woman is welcome i
mean too of course yeah it's gonna be
good honest content there's a lot of
cheesy videos out there that i've seen
but you're a
real woman yes i'm going to be focused
on telling the truth about everything so
guys join my channel see you in my first
video bye that's it cheers